I
he was once the world's most famous male
model even his looks were household
names
leti grrah Magnum and of course blue
steel but that was a long long long time
ago old LeMay we were joke up there his
fashions change meet the biggest
supermodel the whole world is all are
you like a male model or a female model
all is all I think he's asking do you
have a hot dog or a bun Derek Zoolander
I'm with Interpol I need your help she's
hot I trust her
someone's trying to kill the world's
most beautiful people
Oh foot so well all of them died with
your signature look
this is Brustein right we need you to
infiltrate the world of high fashion
we're back
we sure do laughter is right now help us
hey handsome
you were amazing
I'm sorry I can't understand a word that
you're saying uh-huh Eric Koston tonight
you've got it
there's only one criminal mastermind who
could be behind all this prison changed
me
I am bad to the core now
talked where's my goddamn latte but how
am I supposed to stop him got to I'm the
mom of a Java I'm in found by you Adama
you're Derek Zoolander stop the Chinese
throwing star with a look
flash me that beautiful mag wait Magnum
now maybe we could try a wash go